それで あの 仏教はこの一応シンプルな単純化を教えているというテーマなんです
で まあ最初にこの一つ例えで言えば
あれ 編み物に使われる毛糸の何て言いますか
毛糸の毛糸ですかね まあ糸ありますね
その糸の玉をね まあ一つ猫にあげて
一つ人間にあげたらどうなるかと
まあまあ猫にあげたら
まあそれでまあむちゃくちゃ遊んで
まあかなり複雑になるんですね
人間だったら それは丁寧に巻いて
まあ適当な編み物はする
それで猫と人間の差はどちらにあるんですかというと
猫はバカで 人間には頭があるというぐらいの話でしょう
だからシンプルになるということは賢いということなんです
だから賢い人は物事はもうとてもとても単純でシンプルで見るんですよ
それで我々人間がこの猫と毛糸の例えのように
人間として生きることはあまりにも複雑にしていて
それはまあ単純にしようではないかという
その方が楽じゃないかと
その方が楽しいんじゃないかというのは
一応仏教の一つの立場なんですね
まあ解脱悟りということを置いておいて考えると
お釈迦様が日々楽しく明るく生きることがもう大変良い生き方だとは認めているものなんですね
まあそれでこのお釈迦様に聞かれたある質問があって
あの アントジャタバヒジャタジャタージャティターパジャ
タンタンゴータマプッチャーミ
コーイマンヴィジャタージャタン
アントジャタ 内心というか
心の中 内側 ものすごく複雑に編み込まれて
もうもう結び高いですよと
心の中 バヒジャタ その人の外の世界との関係を見ても
あらゆるからくり からくりがあって
ものすごい複雑になっているんだと
一人の人間の生き方を見ると
内でも心の中でもものすごく複雑になっちゃって
どうにもならん状態で
で その人の世間的な関係を見ても
すごく複雑になって もう絡み合ってどうにもならんと
ですから ジャタージャティとパヤ
パジャっていうのは 人々はジャターっていうのは結びですね
そうやって結びからもうものすごく編み込まれて複雑になっているんだと
で 最後の行だけ書くならば
ジャターヤ ジャタっていうのは言葉っていうのは
この糸を結ぶことなんですよ
だから結んで結んで その上さらに結んで
その上さらに結んで その
そうすると 糸を 1本にすることはもう到底無理なんですよ
パジャっていうのは 人々はこの生命が結びから結びで
もうあまりにももう結ばれている
なんかかっこいい言葉に聞こえますけど
やっぱりジャタといえばもうそんなにかっこいい言葉じゃないんですよ
引っかかっているということなんですよ
引っ張られて引っかかっているという
まあだからこの糸が結ばれていると思っちゃえばね
せっかく刺繍をなんとかしようかなと思ったところで
糸巻きあっちこっち結ばれて
もうどうにもならん状態だったら
もうどうにもならんですよ
これが その意味でジャタ結びっていう言葉を使っているんです
ですから 混乱中混乱であると
生命は  一般的な現代的な日本語にするならば
まあ生命は混乱中混乱であると
訳になります それでタンタンゴータマプッチャーム
その問題をゴータマに聞きます
こうイマンウィジャタへジャタン
誰がこの複雑な混乱状態を平安な綺麗にしますかと
だからジャタっていうのは結ぶことですから
ウィジャタっていうのは解くことなんですね
誰がその結びを解きますかと
それにお釈迦様がなさった答えをテーマにしてて書いた注釈書なんですよ
この清浄清掃浄土論何でしたっけ
え？浄土論というテキストがパーリ語でビスッディマッガというんですけど
現在 このテーラワーダ仏教という宗派が大体この浄土論に書かれている基本的なところをメインにして実践しているんですね
私はあえてテーラワーダ仏教というものを言っているんじゃなくて
お釈迦様の教えをもう喋ってるんですから
まあ結構テーラワーダからは脱線します
で 一応テーラワーダっていうのは日本にある宗派と同じくもう一つの宗派ですから
まあそちらはもう大体メインテキストとして使うのはこのビスッディマッガという本なんですね
まあ日本語で浄土論というふうにありますけどね
日本わからない わからない日本訳もありますけど
読んでも ビスッディマッガ
このビスッディマッガというテキストはもうなかなかのもので
もう相当の天才的な能力がないと書けるものじゃないんです
仏教におけるなんとなくちょっとした百科事典みたいな本
1冊ですけどね 百科事典みたいなもんで
特に修行中心にに必要なものは全部揃ってるんです
だから 残念なことに読書にはならないんですよ
百科事典を楽しみに読むって人っていうのはもうおそらくいないでしょうし
だから百科事典っていうのは
何か分からないところがあったらもう参照する
あれは読書としてはね
あまりならないということを私に言われたら
みんな必ず読んでみるぞということもやりますけどね
それは構いませんですけどね
私に文句を言ってはいけませんと
今日もスライドなんか作ろうと思ったんですけど
また朝もうガチャガチャガチャガチャもういろいろ文句言われちゃって
これにはかなり怒ったんです
いい加減にしなさいと
で それで全部スライド作ることも本当に申し訳ないんです
アイスクリームまで食べて
パソコンまで持ってきて
これはもう私のせいといえば私のせいなんですけど
なんで人のクレームは真に受けるかと
真に受ける必要はなかったんですけど
向こうはこちら したいんだから
もうちゃんとそれに反応してほしいんですね
だったら反応してやるぞと
もう徹底的に混乱させちゃったんですけど
この人のことをね でも人にゴミを流そうと思っちゃうと
私もゴミを触らないとね
だからもう ちょっとそういうことで
心の楽しみが消えちゃったんですよ
だから仕事っていうのは
ニコニコ楽しくて遊びでやらないと完璧な仕事はできない
だからほんのちょっとでも嫌な気持ちがあるともう一つ言ってやるぞって思っちゃ
それに反映するんですよ
だからまあとにかく辞めたんです
まあ悪いのは私かもしれませんですけど
で まあこのヴィソティマッガっていうテキストは
まあ一応この精神的なこの混乱状態はいかに解くかとというテキストで
しかし 何でしたっけ？百科事典風にいわゆる書いてるんだから
読む人にとって関係あるものないものもね
全部リストアップしているんですよ
だから読んでもね そんなに
でもパーリ語で読む場合は役に立ちます
なぜかというと それはいろんな用語の説明だから
すごく役に立ちます  それはテーラワーダ仏教という仏教のことで
まあこちらでは まあ私は別にどちらかの宗派にこだわることではなく
誰の文句も文句言うとこは誰に文句を言いますから
遠慮しないで まあブッダの教えをね
まあ理解しましょうと
ブッダには宗派がありませんし
まあ誰にでも実践できるもので
それでまあ元に戻りますけど
お釈迦様の時代からも人間がなんで複雑ですかと
この生き方っていうのに
当時 インドで別に大したことなかったでしょうにね
まあいくら考えたっても
そんなに国際的にどこかも戦争するならば
もう国はみんな参加しなくちゃいけないとかね
そんなこともなかったし
まあ強いて言えば単純に生きていたんではないかと思いますけど
なのに やっぱりその時代の人々も
かなり心の中で複雑で複雑で生きていたんじゃないかなと思いますよ
この人間の複雑さって何でしょうかね
例えば 昔のインドの人々の複雑な生き方といえば
何なのかね  2000 まあ帰伯もどんで
ほとんど600年ぐらいですからね
2600年 だからそれほど難しい社会構成ですかね
やっぱり我々から見れば
もうなんか単純じゃないかなと思うかもしれませんだけど
やっぱりどんな時代でも人間の生き方っていうのは複雑なんですよ
それが普遍的にお釈迦様が教えていること
例えば この女性と男性の問題にしたってもね
もう複雑ですよ 例えば気に入ってる相手がいる
しかし 一緒になれない
今だったら 日本だったら別に
それはもう互いに気に入ってるんだったら
いとも簡単に一緒になれるでしょう
でも 昔のインドではそう今でもそう簡単じゃないんですよ
もし占いが合わなかったらどうしますかね？ホロスコープが合わなかったら
あなた２人が合わないんだよと言われると
もうそれで結婚できなくなっちゃうんですよ
だから若い２人がただもうそれだけ顔を見ただけで気に入ってるだけのことなんですけど
そこで本人に何の管理もできない
生まれた時の星の並べ替えをね
勝手に親が調べて あんた２人は会いませんと
と言うと もう大体できなくなっちゃいますよ
大体はほぼ95%以上はホロスコープ合わないと結婚しないんです
今でも だから日本より複雑ですよ
それでホロスコープが合ったとしましょう
しかし 家が違う 家の階級制度っていうものあるんだから
だから別な階級の家とは結婚しないんです
するならば もうやっぱり別などこかで強引で生活するしかないんですよ
だから簡単じゃない あの人のこと気に入りましたと
その人も じゃああなたのこと私も気に入りました
では一緒になろうと そう簡単じゃないんですよ
だから複雑っていうのはそんなもんで
やっぱりインドの人々にはまあ結構人生は複雑でしたなとは思いますよ
それ自体弱くなくて このお釈迦様の時代っていうのは戦国時代でしたからね
戦国時代というんですかね
まあこれ私は勝手に作っている言葉でね
あのお釈迦様が生まれるちょっと前からのインドの国がかなり小さな国々に分かれてあったんですけど
それはこの分解してね
壊れて壊れて 力強い国に統一していったんですよ
それはもう何百年も続けたんですよ
全部まとめたのはもう随分後で
このアショーカ帝王の時なんです
だからかなりお釈迦様は紀元前500というのは
700年  800年の間でずっと変わっていったんですよ
だからこれは一番軌道に乗っていた時はお釈迦様の時なんですね
で どういうことかと お釈迦様の国が滅びちゃったんだから
お釈迦様が生まれた国が
もう家に戻って王様になろうと思ったって国はなかったんです
後で考え方が変わって
もう滅びちゃったんです
それはまあこうする国に侵略されちゃってる
それはまあそっちは起きてるんですよ
それで考えてください
ある民族が自分たちである地方で
私たちの国やということで
例えば東京都ではなくて東京国とかね
大阪共和国とかね そういうふうな国みたいな感じでいだと
これでみんな仲良くまとめて生きているところで
いきなり壊れて 別な人々やらしきたり習慣が入ると
これすごい複雑になるんですよ
生き方は それで悲しみっていうのは並大抵のものじゃないんですよ
自分の親戚やら家族やら殺されるは
しかし抵抗できない だからこの政治的にはかなり複雑で不安であります
政治的な不安というのは直接家に入るもんなんですよ
自分の家の旦那がいつ殺されるかわからない状態にはなるんですね
政治不安というのは だからやっぱり複雑でしたんではないかなと
だからこの知識人たちが
インテリの人々が何なのか
これはと なんで人間に単素で単純単純で生きていられないんですか？と
という疑問があって それはお釈迦様に出されたということなんですね
しかし この質問の答えは修行ですから
今日のテーマには合わないんですよ
このこの芸にヴィスッディマグガというテキスト
かなり厚いテキストでずっと続けて答えているし
で まあお釈迦様 だからそれは修行の世界で
もっと単純に社会的な問題を考えてみようかなと今日思っています
こちらにお釈迦様がおっしゃっているのは
このまあ道徳的になりなさいと
まずシーラですね この道徳っていうのは人生を単純にすることなんですよ
例えば嘘をつくことがえらい複雑なことなんです
人を嘘をついて騙すということは
かなりからくりしないとできるものじゃないんです
ただ無知でただ嘘を言うんだったら
簡単に馬鹿にされるんですよ
社会から追い出される
ですから 嘘をつく人々は結構ずる賢くて
バレないようにしないと嘘にはならないんですよ
それでもバレないように嘘をついちゃっても
言ったことは事実ではないんだから
バレる可能性はいつまでもあります
事実は事実ですから だから
それから死ぬまで怯えて生活しなきゃいけないんです
賄賂してないんだと言っても
本当に取っているんだったらいつかバレる
だからかなり人生が複雑になる
国会でハイとはいかないか
しっかり答えなさいと答えられないんですよ
いろいろ逃げ回りしなくちゃいけないんですよ
それでわけわからなくなって
何言ってるんですかと
やっぱりそうやって 例えば嘘をついちゃうと
その時点で人生が複雑になるんですね
だから戒律を守るっていうことは
例えば嘘をつくない 単純になれっていうことなんですね
取ったら取ったよと言うだけのことなんです
ぶったらぶちまちちゃうと
それで問題は済みますよ
例えば我々 スイスイいろんな悪いことをしちゃうし
それはもうあんたやったんではない
ああ まあそうなんですよと
私ですよ 言えば ものすごく見事に解決するんですよ
だから人間がもし嘘を言わないならば
こんな複雑な警視庁やら
ものすごいややこしい複雑な裁判制度やらね
あの法棒 分厚いね あのあれ
法棒というんですか あんなものとかね
いらなくなっちゃうんですよ
ずいぶん単純で 人間悪いことをしないとは限らないんだから
まあもう法律 複雑な法律なくても
人は人を殺したりする可能性はあります
それでも嘘をつかない
正直な人だったら 申し訳ない
私がやりましたと では
それなりの罰を決めることはとても簡単なんですよ
それでももう頑固と戦うんだからね
自分が悪いことしているのに
だからそれにすごい時間とエネルギーとかかるし
大変ですよ とにかくお釈迦様の答えはもう戒律さえ守れば単純になるんでしょうと
だから特にこの戒律に対して
よくまあ これはもうどこでも誤解あるんですよ
あれは嫌なもんやと 道徳を守ることはね
わがまま放題で生きることが楽じゃないかという心がわがまま放題で生きたがるんですよ
そこでお釈迦様が言うのは
あんたはね わがまま放題で生きたいと思っているんだけど
できないんだと だから私がわがまま放題で生きている方法を教えてあげますという道なんです
このわがまま放題で思っている人々には
全然それができないんですよ
だってわがままでいい加減で
人の話は聞かないわ 間違いだらけで
もう犯罪までするわ 人生失敗だらけで
もう何一つも自由にできなくなるんですよ
このわがまま放題だと思っている人々が
例えば二人がいて 一人がわがまま放題
もう一人がやっぱりみんなの気持ちも考えて
世間のことも考えて それなりに自分を抑えている人と比べてみると
すごい自由に生きているのはその自分を抑えている人なんですよ
誰もその人には断りしませんからね
その人に何か頼まれたら
何のことなくやってくれる
その人何か言ったら みんなそうですかというふうに信頼してくれる
だから単純で自由なんですよ
わがまま放題で もう人の話は聞かない人に何か言われると
みんなやっぱりやってくれない
それでわがまま放題そのものがなくなっちゃうんですね
それで戒律なんかになってくると
そういう人々はなんか嫌なものだなとかね
思ったりはしますけど
それは心の問題で だから自由になりたいが自由になれないというね
心の性質はあるんだからね
わがままで自由に生きていきたいんですからこそ
もう森の中で迷子になる
というになるんですよ
だからちゃんと道があるんだから
看板をかけているんだからね
ここから左に曲がれとかね
ここはまっすぐに行けとかね
だからそれ歩めばいいっていうことで
それを歩みたくないんですね
だから戒律なんかにはちょっと違和感というものは感じますけど
これは自分たちがね 我々の心が悪いんであって
実際は戒律っていうのはものすごい簡単単純で
生きるための手段なんですよ
例えば これはありえない話です
例えば 日本の社会は殺生しない主義だと
日本の憲法は戦争をしない平和憲法だとハッキリすれば
世界の笑いものにならないでしょう
このアメリカはイラク攻撃を応援して
日本だけ なんかもう 私はもう日本にいるんだからね
これちょっともうなんかちょっと自分の立場までまでも
なんか変に感じちゃうんですよ
だから余計なことを考えなきゃ
堂々と言えばね 私たちにとっては
これは憲法上はもうどうにもできませんと
すみませんでした その方が答えが簡単に出てきますよ
いかなる場合でも殺しは良くないと
だから 別にそれはありえない話でと仮定的に喋りますけど
例えば人は殺しませんよと
もう決めたと 決めちゃえば
それ時点からもうすごいスムーズに物事がいくんです
殺してもいいやと決めちゃうと
なんで殺すんですか？どういうわけで殺すんですか？とか
あらゆる複雑な条件を作らなくちゃいけないんです
そういうことですから
やっぱりこのお釈迦様その戒律なんか守ってみればもう簡単でしょうと
2番目に言うのは 精神的に落ち着けと
そうするとガチャガチャガチャガチャ思考がなくなるでしょ
3番目に言うのは 頭がね
もうちょっと頭がいい方に
いわゆる知恵を開発しなさいと
だから猫ではダメなんですよ
猫には編み物できませんだからね
この間すごい面白いテレビコマーシャルを見たんですけど
猫の餌のテレビコマーシャルなんですけど
なんか猫の前にマイクロフォンつけてあって
新聞なんか見ると無性に面白くなるんだぞと猫が言うんです
言って 人が新聞読むところに飛び上がってむちゃくちゃするんですね
新聞は すごいかわいい
面白いコマーシャルなんですけど
まあそんな感じでね 猫の猫は新聞が面白いと無性に面白くなるんだぞというのは
もう好きでたまらんと
といっても これ 人間が新聞が好きでたまらんということとはえらい違うんですね
むちゃくちゃにすることになっちゃうんですよ
でも人間だったら情報を読んで新聞を畳んで置いておく
その方が単純ですけどね
ですから 猫の精神ででは
何て言いますか 単純化は難しいんですね
ですから 知恵の開発っていうのはどうしても必要なんです
だから単純イコール知恵なんです
だから単純とはシンプルというシンプリシティ
シンプルであることは
それがウィスダムなんですよ
だから英語でかっこつけて言うならば
シンプリシティイズウィスダム
あるいは逆に言ったって同じこと
ウィスダムイズシンプリシティという風に
ですから 私はこれからテーマを決めた
ワイズイズシンプルというテーマで
まあなんとか強引に日本語にしましたけどね
コピーは私のものじゃないんですけどね
別にコピーライターがいるんです
私はアイデアだけ  ちょっと余計な話になりますけど
あの まあお釈迦様からあまり評価できない単純化もあります
でも思想的にはすごい単純ですけど
お釈迦様は評価しないんですね
これは一つ このお釈迦様の時代にあったこの一信教ですか
それはもうすごい単純ですよ
しかし お釈迦様はそれは評価しないんです
で その一信教というインドにあった宗教っていうのは
この神が一切を創ったんだから
何であろうとも それ神の計画通りで起こるものであって
この作られた人間っていうのは
ガチャガチャガチャガチャこんなに踏ん張らなくてもいいんだよと
放っておけばいいんだよと
それがこの今 インドにあるこのバガヴァッドギーターというテキストがありますね
それは単純で ギーターといえばインド人みんなわかります
フルネームはバガヴァッドギーターなんですけどね
バガワっていうのは聖なるという意味で
ギーターっていうのはポエム
歌っていうことでね いわゆるこれは神が言ったことになってるんです
そのテキストでも まあそんなに物事を複雑に考えるなよと
というテーマなんです
今 現在ヒンドゥー教の聖書みたいに大変大事にするテキストで
まあ全部もう神が決めるものだからね
あんたなんか複雑に考えなくていいや
その時その時のことやっておけばいいんじゃないかと
で それは仏教は認めない理由は何なのかというと
例えばそのテキストの中にあるのは戦争するべきかという疑問なんですね
アルジュナが なんで親戚を殺さなくちゃいけないかと
それで考えて考えて落ち込んじゃって
もう戦争をやめる気でいるんですよ
戦闘でね お互いの軍隊が集めているところで
こんなバカなことをやる必要ないんだと
それで神様がというのは
この車の運転手ですけどね
クリシュナがね まあ説法するんです
あんた方決めるもんじゃないんだと
私 何々するという考え方も捨てて
やるべきことをやりなさいと
ということで この戦いを応援するんですね
それで まあこれは全部神様の仕事やということで
その人は戦争するんですよ
だからこの思考的には単純ですよ
だから単純でいいんじゃないかっていうよね
まあいいんですけど 仏教はそれを認めません
なぜかというと このそれだったら世の中良くなるということはありえないんですね
いわゆる運命論ですね
運命で決まっているんだからしょうがないやと
という気持ちが仏教は嫌なんですよ
頑張れば治りますよと
変わりますよと というのは仏教の立場なんです
何でも変わるんだよと
変わらないものは何一つもないんだと
だから放っておいても変えるでしょうし
そこで意図的に変えれば
自分の好みの通りに変わるでしょう
それは否定したくないんですね
仏教は 無常という教えですから
神ではなくて 仏教は無常ということだからね
まあ言葉二つになっちゃって申し訳ないんですけどね
仏教 他の宗教は神たった一つの言葉ですけどね
まあパーリ語だったら言葉一つですよ
アニッチャっていうの
一言葉です まあ日本語になると二つになりますけどね
だからこのアニッチャといえば
もうまあ放っておいたっても
どうせ変わるんだよと
何でも どうせ変えるんだったら
ちょっといい時に変えればどうですかね
するといろいろまあ好みの通りにいきます
人って例えば体はどうせ衰える
変化する それで人間がスポーツやら運動やら体操やらすると
そうすると体が変わるんですよ
でも変わる過程が自分にとっては楽しい過程なんです
でも もうただ何もしないで食べて座っている
寝るだけでも体が変わりますよ
放っておけば しかし その変わり方はあまり気持ちのいい変わり方じゃないんです
それで食料を減らしたりとかね
結構運動したりすると
またここ体が変わる しかし
その変わり方がなかなかいいもんなんですよ
そういうことだから このまあ
あの運命論は認めないんですね
運命だと思って すべて神に決めるものだと思って
私たちは複雑に考えるものではありません
気楽に生きましょうという考え方は認めません
だから変えてちょうだいとお祈りすることも仏教ではない
お前変えなさいと変えなさいと
神に頼むんじゃなくて
という態度は取るんですね
それは仏教だと他の宗教と比べてくると
この出てくる差なんですね
その時 我々また疑問に思う
仏教は業というものを教えているのではないか
と業といえば もうどうしようもどうにもならないのではないか
だからでもそうならないんですね
業だから自分変えますよ
業っていうのは自分の行いだから
だからそれももう簡単に
変えればいいということなんです
そこら辺はあまり仏教は認めない単純さなんです
なぜかというと 戦争は正当化できますよ
この一神教では 人殺しは
で 一神教になると この人を殺してもいいということにはなるんです
戦争好きもいいと で 厳密な一神教になってくると
何が起きてもそれは神が決めたものなんです
前もって定めたものなんです
それで私たちはただその通りに動いているだけです
いくらか自由意志あったとしたっても
それも設定していただいているものだからね
そういうわけで戦争することになったら戦争すればいいんです
人殺してなんで悪いかとか良くないとか考える必要はないということで
堂々とやらなくちゃいけないし
だからそれがもう当然仏教はもう全く認めない
だからあんた方は罪を犯す羽目になるんだと
ということで 立場が違いますから
あの 仏教の考え方というのは
もうたとえ蟻殺したっても罪だよと
生命ですから 生命を殺したら罪ですと
しかし 他の道徳の世界ではいろんな複雑な教えをして
殺してもいい時と殺しては悪い時は決めるんですよ
で この間 最近研究したんですから
イスラム教の場合はやっぱり殺してもいい時と殺してはいけない時っていうのははっきり区別しているんですね
だから 自分の教えを守るために
神を守るためには もう何やってもそれは完璧な良い行為であって
自分同士では決して喧嘩することでも認めない
イスラム同士だったら喧嘩することさえも認めない
しかし それ以外はどうでも頑張ってくださいと
そこでこの質問があって
そのところである人がこの虫やらね
ネズミやら殺したらどうなるんでしょうか？と
それは平気で殺せと 罪になりませんと
人間の害になるものは殺すことは罪にならないと
コーランでちゃんと言ってますよというふうに言っちゃうと
定義次第 あなたは私に対して害になりますよと
ということで殺せます
ですから そこら辺はまあ仏教の立場から見れば良くないというね
やっぱり単純でなきゃダメだと
殺すなかれと言えば 生命も誰でももう関係なく殺すなかれと
殺してはいけないと その方が正しいと
というふうにはなってます
だからそれは仏教はあまり仏教は認めない
単純化なんですね まだたくさんありますけど
そこら辺で省略します
それであの Simplicity
is wisdom というシンプルであることは知恵であると
私は言ったことに なんか皆様よく知っている例があります
12世紀あたりで 道元禅師という人が中国へ行って
年ぐらいかな 年ぐらいで修行してきたんですね
本当に仏教は 仏教は何なのかを理解しなくちゃいけないんだぞっていうことで
真面目な方で で ものすごい真面目に真剣に修行して
日本に来たら あんたは中国に行って
本土に行って何を学んだんでしょうかと聞いたところで
まあどうってことはないんだと
鼻直弦をというものは習いましたと
ちょっと書いてもらえますかね
鼻はまっすぐ 目は横っていう感じです
まあ消してもいいんですけど
弦 目 横 私は学んできたのはそれですよと
必死で修行して これ大体何やこれっていう言葉でしょ
鼻はまっすぐでしょ 別に目は横でしょ
鼻は縦 目は横っていうことなんです
でも これはものすごい立派な言葉なんですよ
だから彼がもうかなり徹してシンプリシティというものはもう経験したんです
かなり苦しい修行の過程を経て
だからそういうこと そこら辺は全敵で
まあ鼻は縦 目は横にあるんだよと
そう簡単には理解できないと思いますけど
まあ私たちはもうなるほどというのを思っちゃいますね
でも 聞く人々はなんか飽きちゃう
なんかすごい 何言うんですかと思うでしょうね
だからあの まあはっきりと道元禅師はいくらかはもうなんかこのわかってはいるんです
しかし まあそれで自慢張ったところで
ちょっと脅かされちゃって
自分の先生に  それからもうちょっとあるんじゃないかっていうね
ところでずっと修行し続けたし
だからそれは素晴らしいね
正直なところはね しかし
これがえらい単純というところはもうとわかってはいます
真理は いわゆるこの仏教でいうこのありのままというね
ありのままに見る と ありのままだったら備蓄言語でしょ
なんでそれ複雑に考える必要あるんですかね
だから仏教はありのままに見る教えだよと
という話ですよ ありのままに見られれば
もう問題はないんだよと
ありのままに見ないんだからこそ
我々にはあらゆる煩悩やら葛藤やら
もういろんなことが出てくるんです
はい まあそれからなんですが
まあ一応そこら辺は一応最初のところで
ちょっと具体的にこの物事をシンプルにする方法を考えてみましょう
具体的な例で えーと  こういう質問の場合は
私たちはいわば正しい人間関係って何でしょうかと
それであまり具体的じゃない
私がどのように人間関係を築けばよろしいでしょうかという問題
私が あるいは私はどのように生きればいいかということなんです
そこはすごい大事な質問で
具体的で実際に生きているんだから
この世の中で 私がどのように人間関係を築いて生きるべきか
その時はこの 何といいますか
前提として一つあります
失敗しないで幸福で成功して生きる方法なんですよ
失敗してもいいんだったら
どんな方法でもいいでしょう
人間関係 何でもいいでしょうに
でもそれは認めません
全くも失敗しないで成功して幸福で生きていきたい
で それには人間関係っていうのはどうしてももう無視できない
もう確実に人間の中で生きているんだから
それで質問になるんですね
私がどのように人間関係を築くべきかと
その質問 そこまでご理解できると思います
大事な質問 では 答えは何ですか？これでは答えられないんですよ
この問題はあまりにも大雑把で複雑なんですよ
では 皆様も今まで人間関係を築きながら生きてきたでしょ
では 一人一人自分で答えてみてください
心の中ででもよろしいんです
心の中で答えたっても
私には一応読み取れます
自分で答えないと まあ言いますよ
考えてないんだよと ちょっと時間あげます
自分自分 自分の心に聞いてみてください
私がどのように人間関係を築けばよろしいかと
各人の人間関係違いますからね
各人に別々 まあそれぞれ答え似てなくてもいいんです
考えた 一人だけに聞きます
まあではどうですか  私はあの大体つのことを考えるようになりました
一つはですね 大体は何かを何かしてくださいと言われると
ちょっと待ってっていうのが私の
あのなんていうか 習慣だったんですけれども
まあ自分のことを考えると
大したことをやってないわけなんで
なんか頼まれたら即やってあげるっていうことを
そういう風に なんかいろんな場面でやるようにしました
すると まあいつの間にか結構いろんなところでは人間関係は良くなったように思います
はい まあなんでこの方に聞いたんですかというと
このまとめな仏教的な答え出すんだからなんです
でも それでは講演は成り立たないんです
で 他の方々に聞いちゃうと
まず答えが出てこない
で それにみんないろいろ考えるんだから
ものすごく頭が混乱するんです
それは具体的にデモンストレーションさせた方がいいんですけど
そうすると講演は行くんだけど
理解はできなくなっちゃうんです
頭混乱して  そういうわけでまとめた答えをもらったんです
で それをその方の生き方よ
みんなに真似できません
で 本当のところ 私が言います
私はどういうふうに人間関係を築けば築けばいいんでしょうかと聞いても
どうでしょうかね ということになるんですね
それはわからないとかね
そう簡単じゃないとかね
ものすごい複雑になるんですよ
答えがないんですよ 本当のところ
今までどのような人間関係を築け築けたかと聞けば
過去のデータだからね
それは言える可能性はありますけどね
これは過去 現在 未来に渡っている質問ですよ
私はどのように人間関係を築けばいいかという
だから答えが出てこないんですよ
それで で こちらの方言ったところに行きます
えーと 一つ簡単な答えを出せる方法っていうのは
まあその都度その都度いいんじゃないかと
そのいわゆるその時その時の自分のアプローチですね
その人との関係において
それなりのアプローチをすればいいんじゃないかなと
というのは 一つの複雑なことは単純になる方法なんですよ
でも それでも実際に生きてみようすると引っかかっちゃうんですよ
言葉はいいんですよ あ
私の人間関係ですかね
あまりわかりませんだけど
その時その時出会う人の条件に応じてやってみますと
いくらかまとめそうなんですが
実際に生きてみるとそううまくいかないんですよ
実際は無理なんですよ
実行するのは それとは
例えばもう期待 考えたこともない
突然何か言われたりすると
どうしようかと その時困っちゃうんですよ
予測もしなかったことを言われたとかね
では どう反応すれば 例えば元気で学校に行ってる子供
子供はまあまあ随分明るくて楽しくて
もうもう家じゅう遊びながら
すごい瞬時に真剣な顔をして
お父さんお母さん 話したいことがあるよと
それで 子供は喜んでいるような感じで
何？と聞くんですね 何か面白い話みたいな感じで
実は私は自殺したいなと
何言うんですかと言うと
その瞬間でショック来ちゃいますよ
考えたこともないことだからね
それからえらく複雑になるんです
関係は もし単純な母だったら
何？実はおかあさん 私は自殺したい
あ そう じゃあやれば？と言えば
そこで問題解決しますよ
私は知ったことじゃないんだから
本当は単純な答えで問題解決します
しかし 私たちは期待してない問題に出会っちゃうと
もう頭パニックになるんですよ
だからその都度適応しますよと言っては
言うのはいいんだけど
実行ではまたトラブル起こります
それがですから その問題はさらに単純にする
さらに単純にする方法って何なのかというと
人間関係 人間関係といっても
私という人が誰と関係を持ってるかということは
これは知られたもんでしょ
結局は 一人の人っていうのは
誰と誰と話して仲良くしているかで
これははっきりと知られているんですよ
もう そんな大きくないんですよ
では 世界を支配しているブッシュさんが大勢の人々と人間関係を持ってると思いますか？じゃないんですよ
これできません ある何人かなんですよ
例えばコングレスで何か喋ろうと言ったっても
みんなに向かって喋って
そうじゃないんですよ
その時もまあ自分がもうその決まってる人と握手をして
決まってる人とテレビ向けてちょっと一言葉喋って
それからもう決まってる秒単位でちょっと手を振ったりとかね
この間チェックしていたんです
全部厳密に アドレスオブザステートオブザユニオンというもの
全部この秒単位でプログラムして
だから本人が自分の演技さえやればいいんですよ
結局 原稿を読めて 読む時でも
普通 アメリカ人が日常的に使っている英語のアクセントではなくて
国際的にわかる理解できる
あのアクセントはアメリカ人にとって難しいんですよ
で 我々はもう第2番目
3番目の言葉として勉強するんだからね
普通なんですけど アメリカ人に聞いてみれば
ああいう風な発音で喋るのは難しいみたいに
で まあ本人の言葉だからね
そこでその決まっているアクセントで読み上げればいいんです
その時も一行読めば それでちょっと
ポーズですよ あのポーズという止まる
それでみんな立ち上がって握手をして
それを秒単位で決まっている
それでみんなまた座る
で また次に次の文章を読み上げると
一回失敗やりましたけど
文章を一つ読んで 次の文章を読み上げようとすぐしちゃったんですね
それで向こうの人々は
準備している人々は立って握手
握手しなきゃいけないでしょ
そこでちょっと それで彼がやめたんで
やめてまたちょっと待ったんです
あそこは失敗だと私は思う
そうやって明確に観察してみると面白いんですよ
ですから この世界で一番の人でも
そんなに複雑にということじゃないんです
ですから その自分の単純作業をするだけ
ですから それは我々にはもう誰もアメリカの大統領にならないでしょうね
侮辱したと思ったってもしょうがないんで
なれないと思いますけど
アメリカで生まれないとできないんです
で 私たちは誰と人間関係
実際に具体的に誰と誰と喋って生きているかということはちゃんとはっきりした方が答えが単純ですよ
ですから 私はどのように人間が生きればいいんでしょうか？ではなくて
それに答えがない 私は誰と人間関係を持ってるんでしょうか？と言えば
あの人とこの人とこの人とあの人ではないかと明確に出てくるんです
だから その人とどう付き合えばということなんですよ
それで出てくるのは このキャタライズ
分類することなんです
そういうわけで 仏教はいつでも分類しなさいよということを言っているんです
大雑把ではダメやと 曖昧で中途半端で
そこで経典なんか読んでみると
いつでも分類 分類 分類
分類ばっかりで 何でも分類していいよ
割愛はもう 3つありますよと
心理は 4つであるよと
人間の生きる道はこれ 8つだよと
では私って？これは 5つだよと
だから私の私学でしょ
哲学っていうのは私学と神学でしょ
西洋哲学っていうのは
インドには仏教になってくると
私はもう無視できないものだから
私は何なのかと問題でしょうに
それは仏教になって私は何なのかで答えてね
私って これは 5つだよと
だから五蘊ですね ルーパ
ウェーダナ サンニャ サンカーリニャ
そうするとあまりにも科学的に捕まえますよ
これ ルーパといえば肉体的な物理的な体
ウェーダナといえば感覚
そんなのは単純でしょう
いかに単純になるかということを分類すると
ではないと みんな幸せって何だろうと
幸せは人間に人間の世間にあるものだろう
天国にあるものだろうとかね
いろいろ喋るでしょ 人に聞くと
いろんな人がいろんなことを言うでしょ
まあ自分が頑張ったことは成功するならば
それが幸せだよと ある人はもう気に入っている人々と仲良くできれば
それこそ成功だよ 幸せだ
いろんなことを言うんですよ
そんなのお釈迦様もくどらない話やと捨てちゃう
それで私って何だろうかとまず見ると
まあ 5つだよと それ以外何かあるかと
あるんだったら言ってみなさいと
全てその中に入っている
だから感覚はどうしますか？と
それから概念思考はどうしますか？と感情はどうしますかと
心はどうします？それだけのことだから
そういうことで いつでも仏教で見られる現象っていうのは
分類すること それですごく単純になります
ですから これからも我々はどんな何か問題にぶつけたら
まず分類してほしいんです
だから今私はサンプルで一つの例を出していきますから
皆様の問題は 皆様一人一人で宿題でやってください
私は人間関係という例を説明するだけ
それで 次 その次の分類ステージに行って
自分が誰と誰と付き合ってますかということははっきりしているんだから
そこら辺で分類してみる
分類してみると 大体これぐらいの分類が出てくると思います
人間といえば必ずしも出てくるのは両親なんですね
両親は関係ないという人々もいますけど
でも両親がなく生まれた人は一人もいませんだから
そういうバカなことを私に言ったっても
何の意味もありません
すごいかっこいい人だと
現代的な人間やと思わないんです
まあ私たちは別に両親のことなんかはもう気にしませんよとか言われたってもね
両親なしに生まれる人がいませんだからね
お化け以外は ですから
誰にでも両親という人間関係があります
それからまあ大人だったら家族という
まあ子供にも家族っていうのはありますけどね
まあ子供にとってはね
そんなに兄弟ぐらいですから
家族は 子供は家族に両親入れてないんですよ
別な枠で生きているんです
だから家族といえば かなりギブアンドテイクできてなくちゃいけないんですよ
大人には家族があります
まあ子供に家族といえば兄弟ぐらい
だから兄弟ではもうそれなりにギブアンドテイクでやりとりしないと
うまくいくわけじゃないんです
それから言えばもう親戚というものがいる
それにはもう代償ありますけど
一応親戚もいるし それから友人たちというね
友達たちもいるし まあそれから同僚と一緒に仕事をする人々やら
いろんなものを教えてくれる人々とかね
それぞれ関係変わるんですよ
親との関係 家族との関係
それから親戚との関係って
すごく変わっちゃっちゃうんですよ
全部具体化するんですよ
私の親戚といえば この人とこの人と
あの人とあの人やと だから
その人々とどう関係を持てばいいかと
すごいわかりやすいんです
その場合は 私の家族で言えば
この人とこの人 この人ででしょと
じゃあ この人々の間でどう生きていればいいかと
すごく頭はクリアにする
この恐ろしいほど単純にするんですよ
例えば うまくいってる人に聞けばね
あんたの人間関係どんなものかと
ああ 私の人間関係というのは十六人ですね
はっきり言えるはずなんです
数えたら十六人ですと
それだったら十六人に対してどんな対応すれば？すごく簡単でしょ
だから大雑把にはしない
で それで先生たちといったのは
教えてもらう人々 やっぱりその関係違いますから
いつでも教えてもらう
指導してもらうということはいつでもあるんだからね
なかなかなくならないんですよ
仕事に行っても 会社に行ってもね
まあやっぱり誰かいるんですからね
こうしなさい ああしなさいという人は
だからそういう関係を気をつけて覚えておかないと
それからもう一つは みんな忘れること
だから仏教 お釈迦様の言葉で言えば
そなたその他というぐらいの言葉なんですけど
それはどういう意味するかというと
具体的にしない人間関係あります
それはどういうことかというと
電車に乗ったら みんなと一緒にいなくちゃいけないでしょ
店に行ったら 店員さんやらいろいろと人間と一緒にいるでしょ
そのその他の人間関係ってそんなそれなんですよ
それがそんなに大変なことじゃないんですよ
電車に乗ったら 座席が空いていれば黙って座ればいいぐらいのことだからね
ちょっともうちょっと空いているんですけど
一人で座れないけど もう一人座りたがってるんだったら
ちょっと寄せて自分が座って
もう椅子は空けた 椅子は座席は空けたけど
それだけでしょう ですから
それは一時的な人間関係
店に行ったら まあこれはどのこの品物はどこにあるんでしょうか？と店員に聞く
その時の聞き方でしょ
お前 これこれはとか言いますかね
この品はどこにあるんですか？とかね
人はそちらなんでそちらに置くんですか？とか
このバカとか言わんでしょ
だからそれぐらいそんな簡単でしょうしね
だからその一時的な人間関係
飛行機に乗ったら降りるまでそれじゃないと一緒にいなくちゃいけない
で そういう風に自分がもうもうもうカテゴライズする
今 一時的な人間関係だよと
親との関係は一時的なものじゃない
子供との関係は一時的なものじゃない
会社の同僚との関係は
まあ一応退職するまでのことで
あるいは転職するところまでのことで
これはもう退職 転職 あるいは他のところに飛ばされるとかありますからね
それだけのことだから
そこははっきりわかっておけば
まあなんとかうまくいく
なんとかではないんですよ
見事にうまくいく 何もなくてもいいことになるんですよ
だから一時的な人間関係と
まあ長い間 死ぬまで待たなくちゃいけない人間関係と
カテゴライズ 分類する
それは必要なんです それ分類できた人にとっても
また問題が来るかもしれません
私の人間関係は 19人ですよと言っても
でももう一人の人は いや
あなた 19人といっても
私の場合は数えてみると 36人ぐらいいますよとかね
と言うかもしれませんですけど
あるいはまあ私にはまあ親しかいないんだよという人人もいるしね
私にはもう今家族もいないし
親もいないし 結婚していないんだから子供もいないという人もいるし
しかし その人には友達がどれぐらいか
あんまり外を出られませんだから
まあまあ一人ぐらいはいますよとかね
友達っていうのは 大人になってくるとかなり数が減るんですよ
この中学生 高校生ぐらいですね
友達がいるの それからほとんど一人か二人か ２
3人ですよ それでですね
そういう風に決めても
分類してはっきり具体的にしても失敗する可能性はあります
感情的になってちょっとうまくいかなかったとかね
だからこちらでポイントは必ずもうまくいってほしいと
たまたま親と喧嘩したっても
本当はどうったことないんだけど
で なんとかもう降りて
なんとか大事な話しようかなと親のところに行ったんだけど
ちょっと話がずれてしまっちゃって
もうもう言いたいことも言わなくなっちゃって
喧嘩になっちゃって もうもう全部もう怒ってもう帰ってしまったとということにはもうあるあるんですけど
まあどうったことないんだけど
それぐらいのことはね
しかし 完璧に成功するんだぞと思う人にとっては
それはちょっと良くない
それだけでも たまたま夫婦喧嘩したってもどうったことはないんだけど
やっぱり人間関係完璧にするんだぞと言ったら
それ たまたま夫婦関係でも失敗は失敗なんです
そういうことだから たとえ分類してもらっても
実際関係持つ瞬間で失敗する場合があります
そこでまた元に戻ります
その瞬間 その瞬間でどうすればいいかと
その瞬間で決めなくちゃいけない
そこで誰と付き合うかということははっきりコンパクトになる
次に その瞬間でこういう風に態度をとる
対処する この場合はこういうふうに対処すると
だから同じ奥さんにしても
二十四時間人間関係あるわけじゃないんですよ
自分の子供とは永久的に死ぬまで関係あると言っても
実際は二十四時間関係あるわけじゃないんです
だから その人にちゃんと関係ある時のみに切るんですよ
その時どうすればいいかと
みんなそれを忘れてるんですよ
夫婦関係ですっごく悩んでるんだよと
笑っちゃいますけど 私だったら
あんた二十四時間その女を背負っているんですか？とかね
でないでしょうに だから実際に具体的に何時何分で一緒にいるかっていうぐらい
その時間でどうすればいいかっていうことで踏ん張っちゃえばいいんです
普通のサラリーマンだったら夜家に戻る
で 朝まで まあ朝までたら寝る時までなんですね
寝ちゃったら何の関係もないんだから
その間で まあもし九時半に家に戻ったならば
まあ十一時半までいることでしょ
その中でも合間でお風呂に行ったりとかね
ありますしね だから よく具体的に考えると
それほど難しいことじゃないんです
で 寝付いたらまあそれで終了ということになるんです
まだ目覚めたところで
朝はまた仕事に出る時間の間で
その間忙しくてね そんなもう夫婦関係とかね
もううまくいかないとそれはなる成り立たないんですね
だからみんなそれを忘れる
例えばそういう風に考えちゃうと
朝は奥さんも早起きする
自分がちょっと遅くなっても送るかもしれない
それで自分が顔を洗って準備してきてると
向こうはもう料理を作って待っているとかね
それぐらいそこで関係がもう成り立つでしょうし
それで自分のために何か尽くしているでしょうに
その時一言言ってあげれば見事にうまくいくでしょうに
そんなに難しいんですかね
それで一言葉言ってあげて
ご飯食べる時は喋れませんし
で ご飯食べて それでもう自分が仕事に行く
仕事に行ってから もう昨日あんなこと言われてとかなんとかとか
何も必要ないんです もう関係ないんですよ
これがこう もう我々はネコの論理で生きているんだから
このなかなかもう引っ張ってくるんですよ
この糸は どこかに引っかかっちゃって
だから分類カテゴリーにして
そのそれからそれを上部
また時間的に割り当てて
やってみると ものすごい人生がもう楽で楽しくて
どこにも失敗ないってことになるんです
会社に入る瞬間で まあこの瞬間からこの人々と生活する
生きるんだよということだから
そこで純然その世界で
生きてみると そういうふうに
その時間 その時間に決まっています
そのようにすればどうなるかというと
例えば夫婦との関係といっても
やっぱり 24時間ではない
1 日何時間かということは出てくる
その時間で その時間でどうするべきかということがはっきり出てくる
そうすると いとも簡単にプログラムを組み立てられます
すごい簡単 だからバカみたくなんですよ
生きることは どこにも失敗もしないし
すごく穏やかで楽しく生きていられます
じゃあ この分類について
社会って何なのかという問題でね
だいたい世間では社会といって大雑把に取りすぎて
社会学やらね 社会の人間として
社会人としてどうするべきかとか
あまりにも喋りすぎ 本書きすぎ
この社会と人間関係のこう
あまりにもありすぎて
もうもう時間ないんですよ
そんなのを読むためには
だから仏教の場合はコンパクト主義だから
そういうふうに喋ります
それでこの長部経典で有名な皆様もとっくに読まれているとは思いますし
何かテキストは編集した覚えがあるんですけど
パティモッダイヌってやったっけ
あのシガーラ経典というね
六法雷なんとか経というふうに日本語で知られている
シガーラという名前の在家の人にお釈迦様が人間関係について説法したんですよ
人間関係ではないだけじゃなくて
君はどう生きるべきかと
それから人間関係をどうするべきかという説法がありまして
悟り 解脱とか五蘊とかややこしいものは何もないし
もうかなり淡々と日常生活のことを言っているんです
で そちらでこの社会というあまりにも大胆で大雑把で把握できない
大きすぎて それをお釈迦様は見事にコンパクトにするんです
それも覚えやすくするように
六方にするんですよ 東西南北上下
見事でしょう この分類のテクニックは
私はどこにいても 私にとっては東西南北上下があるんだから
それが社会になる だからあっという間社会の一員なんです
社会から脱出できません
どこにいても東西南北から脱出できないでしょ
寝ても起きても 何をしたっても
東西南北からは脱出できない
そのように社会というものと自分の生き方っていうのは一緒
ワンセットとする それで東西南北に 6つに単純化したんだから当てはめるんですよ
マーターピターディサープッバ
両親は東 アーチャリアーダッキーナーディサー
教えてもらう人々 先生たち
指導者たちは南 それまたかえって覚えやすいんですよ
この順番が インドでは一番初めの方向っていうのは
東なんです だから東といえばかなりありがたい方向なんです
あんまりありがたくない方向っていうのは西なんです
だから順番いう場合は東から始まるんです
そこで東から時計回りで考えてください
次に来るのは何ですかね
南でしょ そこで自分は産んで育てた親でしょ
東にする 次に自分を育てるのは誰ですかね
先生たちでしょ だからいかに分かりやすくてすごい論理的にこのカテゴライズするかというと
だからアドバイスしてくれるわ
指導してくれるわ もう会社に行ったっても
わからないことはいろいろ教えてくれたりとか
いつでもそういう人々っていうのはいる
だから 親が育てて 親の育ちが終わった時点から
その人々がバトンタッチして死ぬまで頑張ってます
頑張ってくれてるんですよ
大変大事にしないと ですから
南は先生たち 南の次に何が来るんですかね？西ですね
あんまりありがたくないんですね
プッタダーラ 自分の子供たち
あそこ奥さんとかね えっ？うん
自分の奥さんと子供たちって家族です
それほどありがたくない
迷惑ばっかりで インド人にとっては西っていうのはやっぱりありがたくない方向にはなってるんで
だからそういう順番にしているんですよ
お釈迦様のお釈迦様は結構遊んでるんではないかなと思う
いろんな厳密に調べると
説法するとき なんかどこかでちょっとニュアンス
ユーモアがあって なんかちょっとからかっているところは結構見えますよ
そんなに額には冷や汗が出て喋ってるわけじゃないんです
だから そういうふうにしておけば覚えやすいでしょうに
で そこを次に出てくるのは北
で まあ北はね まあもうちょっと怪しい方向なんですよ
良い時もあるし ちょっと困ったなというところもありますよ
北に入れているのは友人たち
まあ本当にありがたくて助かる時もあります
迷惑じゃないかと  とこもないわけじゃないんです
それで 4つ成り立つのですね
それから下は自分が雇っている人々ですね
まあ今日本ではね そんなにある現象ではないんですけど
まあ一応それも一つあるんですね
会社に行けば社長だったらね
課長でも まあまあ 一応ね
そうはなります 一応 まああの
まあはっきりした定義は自分で決める
払ってる人々っていうことなんですけど
だからちょっと会社とかね
ちょっとややこしいなんですが
まあ実際調べてみると
お釈迦様はそういう人々にどうするべきかと教えているところを見ると
それ入りません だからいわゆるお釈迦様おっしゃっているのは
このそういう人々には能力を見て仕事を与えなさいと
適当な時休みあげなさいと
もうちょっと休んでもいいよと
病気になったり なんとかしたら何か出来事起きちゃうと即協力しなさいとかね
それぐらいなんです ですから
課長だったら部下はに対してそうした方がうまくいくでしょう
部下の能力を見て 君これやって
君これやってとかね それでも一生懸命やってあげて
まあちょっと休んだらどうですか？とかね
どこか行って紅茶とコーヒー
紅茶 コーヒーでも飲んできたら？とかね
そうやってちょっと親切に見てみるとうまくいきます
それは下 上はまあ なかなか上がないんですね
日本では これが危険ですよ
爆弾上から落ちるんだからね
全部なくなるんですよ
やっぱり上にもはっきりしたシェルターを作って作っておかないと
では 上から爆弾が落ちちゃうと何が残るんですかね
何も残りませんね 全部パーですよ
だからその方向の中で一番守るべきな上なんです
東から危険が来ると まあ南に逃げればいいんです
南から何か危険が来ると
東に逃げてでもなんとかできますけど
上から来ると 逃げるとこはない
で 上っていうのは こちらはサマナブラフマナということで
自分の宗教の世界なんですね
これは聖職者の世界で
だから上がなくなったっていうことは
これは私たちの誰のせいでもないんですけど
やっぱり社会が変わってるんだから
人間っていうのは あんまり神父さんからね
人生のアドバイスを受けるっていうことは全くしないし
お寺のお坊さんからどうすればいいかということも聞かないしね
もう大体わからない人に聞くんですね
それはもう決まってあって
日本のテレビでもいっぱいアドバイス
カウンセリングあるでしょう
決まってわからない人を選んで聞くんです
その方が番組的に成り立つんです
それだけ役に立つっていうことは関係ないんです
だからそこは真似て みんなも聞いてはいけない人に聞くんです
いわゆるブッダの例えで言えばね
目が見えない人にに絵の具を選んでもらうんです
おまけいきますよ 目が全く見えない人にちゃんとした色
色を選んでくださいと
で これがもう現代社会ではそういうことになってますけど
実際は人間にはやっぱり上が必要なんです
上っていうのは道徳の世界だからね
善悪の世界だから だから悪いことをするなよということは
もう上から教えてもらわないと
奥さんも教えてくれませんよ
奥さんは泥棒しててもお金大金持ってくるとありがたがるんですよ
みんなというわけじゃないんだけど
一般的にはもうそれ以上は私は知りませんと
あの日本で何か北海道でしたっけ？何かちょっとした国際的な問題を受けたでしょ
あのどこかの国の女の人に
あの まあ公のお金をね
大金 青森 チリの女の人に
で 何かという人はもう私は知らんと
そんなことはね そういう態度なんですよ
すごい大金もらって だからその人はそれは私に関係ないんだと
普通はもう一応自分にはお金を送ってくれるんだったらありがとうございますともらうだけで
あんたどうやってこんなお金をする調べないんですよ
本当に夫婦はすごいお互いに心配する兄弟夫婦だったらね
そうはうまくいかない
だからお釈迦様は夫婦のカテゴライズありますよ
何でも仏教はもう分類です
何でも分類 夫婦は何なのか言えば
親みたいな夫婦 で 兄弟みたいな夫婦
友人同士みたいな夫婦
泥棒の夫婦  笑い 泥棒同士の夫婦という風に型暮らししています
それからもう一つあります
あの召使いみたいな 召使いみたいな夫婦と ７
つあったっけ？あったかどうかよく覚えているのは５つだけだからね
まあこれで十分でしょう
笑 それでまあ 親みたいな夫婦の場合は
相手のことは親みたいに心配して守ってくれる
親みたいという場合は
もうまあ親だから まあ蹴ったりぶったりいろいろありますよ
そういう関係 で まあ兄弟じゃなくて
まあ兄弟夫婦はまあそれでまあ兄弟みたいな感じでということで
あの友達の夫婦はそれで友達みたいな平等な関係でまあ仲良くすると
泥棒っていうのはやっぱり
まあ例えば夫の場合 夫の財産はとにかく自分のおしゃれやら何から何まで使うんであって
家の管理はにはお金出さないと
で 昨日かテレビでそんなちょっとしたものが見たんですけど
なんかアメリカ人の人と結婚している女の人で
どちらでもかなり大型なんですね
体は で まあ大した番組じゃない
ただまあ面白い番組というぐらいのことでね
で まあ言いたいことがあるんだと
奥さんに言いたいことは
この人はもうまあまあ
若い時 兵隊として日本から来て
まあアメリカから来て
それでこの女の人のことを気に入って結婚して
日本に住むようになって
その自分がいるところの清掃職
何て言いますか ゴミ屋敷
何て言いますか 清掃ね
そこで仕事をしているんです
で 困ったこと何なのか
でも奥さんがSMAP２ですね SMAP
というグループがもうどこで公演やってもそちらに行きます
笑 家中そのSMAPグッズだけだと
自分の財布にもSMAPの写真だと自分の写真はないんだと
で アメリカ人にとっては財布っていうのは必ずしも家族の写真を入れてるんだから
まあこれちょっと寂しいというか
なんか困ったっていうことで SMAP
の写真もあるんですけど
自分の写真はないと 家ではどこにもないんだと
そこでこういう遠い北海道とか
そこら辺で公演なんかあると
もうずっと奥さんがそちらに行ったっきりで
で まあどう見たっていい年してっていう気持ちもなるないわけないんですけどね
まあそれで自分も一応お金どうするの？お金ないです
まあ自分も一応バイトするんだって
このバイトのこのSMAPが公演に行かない時期があるみたいは知らなかったしね
ある時期になってくると
まあ全国ツアーやらいろいろやっていて
その間でバイトする ツアーがない時はバイトして
そのお金と で またツアーが始めると本人もどこでも行く
ただ行ってもう見ているだけのことですけど
別にまあ仕事してるわけじゃ何の関係もないんで
ただのファンでね それでおくさんの旦那の手紙にね
1 日 500円ぐらいでもくださいと
私に 私もたまにフライドポテトぐらいは食べたくなりますよ
そしたらテレビの人はもうあんた
先生があれ小遣いあげてないの？あげてないんだよ
なんだよ うちはお金がないんだ
この奥さんの態度 じゃあそんなお金がないんだと
旦那に 1 日 500円ぐらいあげたってもね
まあ子供でもあるまいし
まあ子供にも 500 以上はもらいますけど
それさえもしないで 自分がもうSMAP は大好きで
もうもういくらでもお金使いますよっていうのはね
まあまあ 番組は一応面白おかしく終了させましたけどね
番組の方はね いっぱいポスター作って
本人のポスターやらカードやらね
奥さんがちょっと外へ出て行ってもらって
全部貼っちゃって いろいろ
まあそれはまあただ遊ぶ番組と面白くはやりましたけど
やっぱり悪く見ればね
やっぱりあまりね 良くないでしょ
またまた公で言えないこともいっぱいテレビで言いましたけどね
まあ泥棒夫婦にはそんなにそれでも流行らないと思いますけどね
まあしかし やりすぎというのはやりすぎなんですね
だから泥棒夫婦というのは
この旦那の財産はあれやこれやと自分一人のために思い存分使って
もう旦那としてはもう何もない
家族にとっても 家族には我慢しろと言いながら
自分では我慢しないという
まあそういう風にもう夫婦関係にしたっても
お釈迦様は分類する 分類すると
自分の相手がどんなものかとわかるんですね
で まあ分類すぎて この宗教のことに入りますけど
だから言ったのは このたとえ自分の奥さんにしたっても
悪いことをしてはいけませんよという場合も言わない場合多い
良い場合はあるかもしれませんだけど
言わない場合は多い お金がなくなったら
もう旦那がサラ金に手を出したっても
もう黙っている可能性はある
それで追っかけてくると
じゃあ逃げましょうとかね
か あんた逃げなさい 私は知りませんよという場合でしょ
結構あることっていうのは
このリストラになってクビになったら必ず次に離婚なんですね
だから心配してないんですよ
給料もらう間はもう一応料理作ったりお風呂入れたりはする
これから給料もらわないんだと思ったら
すぐ離婚して別れるというね
ですから 我々には正しい立派な人間で生きるためには
奥さんは相手にはなりませんし
奥さんにして旦那も相手にはなりません
だから上が必要なんです
地方から問題が出てくると逃げればいい
上から降りて降りてくると逃げる場所はない
ということで お釈迦様は道徳ね
善悪の場合はちゃんとしたアドバイザーをつけてくださいと
いないんじゃないかと聞いたっても
私は知ったことじゃないんです
昔はまあやっぱりね 宗教はすごい大事な一部だと
人間の 司法よりも大事な一部ですよ
これ 現代人があまりにも人生複雑にしてしまって
余裕がない 暇がない 善悪のところじゃなくて
もうもう 1 日の仕事で全部能力も知識も力ももう尽くして終わってしまうんだから
もう考える暇はない 夫婦関係
家族関係 こんな余裕はない
家に戻るともうヘトヘト疲れてあって
そのままもう布団に入り潜り込んで寝るだけ
だからそれが幸せだとみんな自慢しているんだから
こちらでも何も言うことはできませんだけど
仏教はもう幸せじゃないんだと
貧乏でしょうと あんた方も
って言うんですよ だからそんなに苦労しなくても
もっと豊かですごく楽しく生きていられるはずなんです
余裕があって 遊ぶ時間もあって
子供と遊ぶ時間もあって
家族でどこかへ出かける時間もあってとかね
その上 精神的なことも勉強する時間もあって
仕事も見事にうまくいってとか
その道あるんですよ 問題を単純にするならば
そういうことで お釈迦様はすごくうまく
この六方に人間関係分類していますよ
覚えやすいしね ちょっとインド的に東はありがたい方向だと覚えておけば
それからざっと時計回りでいきます
すべての人間の人間関係はそれに限ると
それに限る しかし 私は余計なことを言ったんですね
一時的な人間関係 それは私が強引に現代社会にて付け加えたもので
それが別にお釈迦様が説法するぐらいの話ことじゃないんですね
でも 死ぬまでの人間関係といえば
この 6つなんです はい
それで分類して単純化する
この私はどのように人間関係築ければよろしいかなという問題は
それでお釈迦様の答えを出しました
さらに単純化することはできます
例えば奥さんとの人間関係というのは 1 日せいぜい 30 分だよとわかった人がね
実際の関係はまあ 1 日 30 分ぐらいでしょうと
30 分よりあるかもしれませんが
わかりません 私は家族生活したことはないんだからね
まあ朝は大体 15 分とかね
まあ夜は入ってご飯食べる時間やらね
お風呂に入るときは関係はないし
また寝る間はそんなどれぐらい時間かかるのかわかりません
具体的にわからないんだから
あまり言いにくいんですけど
だから大雑把で 30 分 1
時間にしましょう  30 分短すぎだったら
具体的に奥さんとの関係はまあ 1 時間だと知っても
その 1 時間ででも何かトラブルの可能性あります
その時も奥さんに何か言われたらうるさいやと言われる
自分言う可能性あります
そんなごちゃらんこと言うも言う必要ないんではないかとかね
そうすると向こうはそれに感化怒っちゃうしね
そこはやめる方法があります
それで我々はなぜ人間関係はギザギザになるかというと
感情ですよ 自分の感情
だから自分の感情を出すた時点で人間関係壊れています
自分が機嫌悪くて 例えば新聞読みたくて読みたくて
あるいはテレビの漫画とかアニメーション見たくて見たくてたまらんのに
まあまあ大人だから漫画じゃないでしょ
まあ野球中継とかね 見たくてたまらんのに
奥さんが横から来て話しかけてくると
あっち行け うるさいと言っちゃうでしょうに
これでもう夫婦関係がもうすごいもう壊れてしまう
まあ強行であっち行け
ボケと何とか言ったら
奥さんはもうテレビ中継ある間は話しかけないと
ませんだけど 本人は自分がリストラになったと聞いた瞬間で離婚するんですよ
確実に やっぱり夫婦とリストラになっても
会社クビになっても 互いに三脚で
生活することですよ 二人組み合えばね
できんことはないんだからね
だからまあそんなにつまらないでしょ
それで立派な社会ですかね
やっぱりどうなっても
まあ二人も三脚で いろいろまあ苦労があろうとも
幸福があろうとも それは全部分け合って乗り越える
乗り越える方法が幸福でしょうしね
成功でしょうし まあそういうことだから
ちょっとした失敗でもよくない
それでもううるさい もうあっち行けボケと言っちゃうと
自分がこの何て言いますか
この中継みたい 野球の
やっぱり自分の感情でしょ
感情を出した瞬間で切れてるんですよ
人間関係 だから感情は出さんこと
感情を出すと終わり そういうことで
まあ時間的にすべての人間関係をすぐコンパクトにする
して その時その時でも感情だけは絶対出さないと
会社でも同じこと 感情で言っちゃったらもう関係はないんです
その瞬間で 例えば自分が必死でもうテレビ中継見たいと
それで奥さんも話があるんだと言ったら
感情を出さないで ああ
そうですね では このテレビ中継見てからもう話しましょう
約束だよとかね 一言言えば感情じゃないでしょ
と言ったら いえ そこまで待てませんよと
あ そうですか だったら二人で中継見ながらしゃべりましょうと
だからどちら？それどちらか降りて
どちらか中道的なとこを突っ込んこないんというのは成り立ちませんだからね
それはどうしても出てきますよ
それでお子さんがいいよ
そんな暇がない 私はもう台所の片付けありますよと
だったら片付け終わってからテレビ中継も終わってますから
その時話しましょうよと言えばいいでしょうに
自分にはもう今しか暇がないんだと言ったら
では二人でテレビ見ながらしゃべりましょうと
それで感情を出しちゃうとね
うるさいと もうそれで関係は終わっているんです
ですから 人間 私はどういうふうに人間関係を築けばいいかという質問には
答えは簡単で 感情を出す中で
それで答えですよ だから単純でしょ
そうやって知恵のある人は
問題はすごい単純で分厚い
あの10冊 20冊のテキストはいらなくなっちゃうんです
一行で 感情を出さず生きる
それで完璧に生きていられます
いますけど 私はこのもう別にあえて例一つ出せません
これ全てというわけじゃない
人間関係というね 私がどのような人間関係を築けばいいかと
その具体的な例に説明していくんですね
この単純化の方法 プロセスを
それで まあもっと一番簡単な方法っていうのは
まあ慈悲ですよ これは人間の道は慈悲ですよっていうのは仏教の教えなんですね
我々は一切の生命に対して慈しみの気持ちで接しなくちゃいけない
自分がそうなってきているんだから
一切のものに対していわゆる何の差別もしない
何の区別もしない 何の分別もしない
相手誰であろうか 自分の心の中では幸福で幸せでいてほしいという気持ちというのは
それが自分の生き方としてね
また仏教の教えでもあるし
それさえ守れば完璧に全部守っちゃいます
上から爆弾が落ちることもなくなっちゃうんです
罪を犯せるかね おるんですよ
慈しみがあれば 慈悲があればもう罪は犯せないんですよ
人も喧嘩を売らないんです
だから自分も喧嘩する必要はなくなっちゃう
だから人間 かなりこの不幸
例えばこの会社クビになったところで奥さん離婚しましたっていうことは
やっぱりすごいかわいそうでしょうし
不幸でしょうし だから互いに一緒にいた時でも
お互いに心配なかったんですね
なんか商売的な関係で
人はお金を持ってくる
私は料理を作ると それがすごくつまらないんですよ
もうものすごい不幸な関係なんです
だから ずっとどんなことにおいても
互いに心配するこの慈悲がある場合は
もうそういう問題何一つも起こらない
仕事はうまくいくわ もう収入も入るわ
だから私たちはよく忘れているんです
だから例えばどうやって儲かるかと
この儲かるっていうことは
外から収入が来ることでしょ
そちらに慈悲がなければ来ないんですよ
例えば 敵が私を奢ってくれるというんですか
奢るんですか？食事してくれることは
私のこと大嫌いな 私をもうできれば殺してやりたいと思っている人がいて
私にどこかご馳走してくれる可能性はありますか？ないでしょうに
だから たまに誰かに奢ってもらったっても
そこで互いに仲良く楽しく友情関係ある時なんですよ
だから収入っていうのは慈悲から出てくるんですよ
もしそちらに欲なんか入っちゃうと慈悲が消えちゃうんです
金儲かりたいという欲は慈悲が消すんですよ
欲が慈悲を消すんですよ
私は儲かりたいということは
相手のことはどうでもいいということなんです
で 慈悲が消えちゃう だから欲張りは気持ち悪くて
みんなに嫌悪される と
で 慈悲があると欲が死んじゃう
欲が死ぬんだけど 収入はもう勝手に入ってくる
それで幸福に生きてられます
だから そんなに簡単なく単純な方法はないんです
例えば 例えば皆様もよく困るでしょ
仏教は欲は良くないと言うんだけど
仕事なんか欲がないとできるわけないとかね
商売なんかできるわけないんじゃないかと思うでしょうに
それはその通りなんですよ
今の世界では欲がないともうどうにもならんということ
だから不幸なんだと言っているんです
それを解決する方法は欲ではなくて
慈しみ 生命のことを心配する
すべての生命のこと 相手は誰でもいいやと気にしないと
ただ心配する そうすると欲が見事に下がって沈んでくれる
心に欲が消えると 人がすごく輝いているんですよ
欲張りはすっごい気持ち悪いんですよ
わがまま欲張りってのはすごい気持ち悪いですよ
どう見たっても そうするとすごく自分が軽くて
もう太陽のようになってくるし
もうもう外からはいくらでも収入が入るようになる
だから豊かに だから慈悲さえあれば経済的にも豊かになる
人間関係っていうのは見事に完璧にうまくいく
何の問題もない だからややこしいのは
論やら社会論やら 会社で能力をアップする方法なんぞやとかね
そういうややこしいことは全部忘れて
単純で慈悲だけ実践してみる
いかに余裕が出てくるかと
だからすっごく楽しく生きてる
見事にうまくいきます
絶対失敗しない それで慈悲についてみんなまた複雑に考える
それが慈悲じゃないんです
例えば なんでコンパッションと慈しみ
慈悲を実践しなくちゃいけないんでしょうかねとかね
考えると それが慈悲じゃありません
わけ探してるんだから
理由を探してるんだから
訳理由を探してるということは
やりたくないってことなんです
やりたくないっていうことは
やっぱり慈悲がない 恐ろしいっていうことなんです
だから 全くも言い訳も論理も調べないで
ただいたずら慈悲を実践する
それが本物の慈悲なんです
ということで 慈悲についてまたちょっと講演になってますけど
その時は他宗教のことを調べたところで
あの 慈悲深きのは神なんですね
それで神から降りて降ってくるものが慈悲
もうそういう愛であって
慈悲であって だから我々はどうすればいいかっていうことはないんですね
で 隣人やら人を愛することをなんとかなんとか言ってますけど
なんか言い訳言ってるんですね
で 言い訳っていうのは
自分が隣人を愛しなきゃ
神は自分のことを愛してくれないと
逆に神が自分のことを愛してくれたんだから
自分が隣人を愛すると
どちらでも汚れてますよ
神が私のことは限りなく愛してくれた
ですから 私は隣人も愛してあげるとということは
理由が上がってるんですよ
だったらそうすると慈悲がなくなっちゃう
もし神に裏切れたら あんたは隣人愛しないでしょうと
っていうことになるんですね
逆に隣人を愛しなきゃ
私は神の裁きを受けますよと思っちゃうと
これ商売なんですね 隣人を愛することによって
敵を愛することによって
神からご褒美いただこうではないかと
商売であって それで教えが崩れちゃいますね
神は完全たる慈しみであるよと
ゴッドイズモストコンパッショネートと言ってます
特にコーランを訳する場合は
アッラー モストコンパッショネート
オンリーゴッドというふうに訳するんですね
1 行目は モストコンパッショネートとか何とか
慈悲深きとかね って言っても
裁くんだからね そこで教え
自分の教えがちょっと崩れちゃうんですね
それは仏教から見たもう批判だからね
そう 宗教を信仰する人は別にもう何考えててもいいんですけど
だからそこを仏教はもうそこもダメよ
汚れてるんだよではなくて
いたずら生命を 慈しみで見てみると
だから 例えば聖書で真ん中にあるこの歌みたいなところがあるんですね
そこら辺でこのすごいこの敵を愛することを美しく語っているんですよ
文章ってすごい立派で綺麗に書かれてますけどね
それを読みながら私は思ったのはね
そんな大げさなことという感じなんです
もう確かに文章は美しい
綺麗ですよ しかし 私はそんな大げさなこと
仏教では大げさにしてないんですよ
敵を愛するということはね
それぐらいもう全くいたずら慈しみなんです
だから神がいてもいなくても生命を愛する
神にご褒美がもらってももらなくても生命を愛する
神にあなたのことを審判でも裁こうそうと言ったっても
それでも生命を愛すると
それぐらいのとこだからね
敵まで愛しなさいっていうのはね
そんなに大げさに言わなくても
一応それは人間は弱いんだから言っておかなくちゃいけないんだから
お釈迦様は言っておきます
例えば 嫌なことを言われる人に対して怒るんだったら
これ誰にでもできますよと
あなたできている人間かっていうことはそこでわかるんだよと
嫌なことを言われても
怒り 怒りなく 憎しみなく
相手に対して慈しみを育てる
それがもうできてますよと
だからこのあれ 鋸の経典で最後に鋸であなたをもう切断しても
嫌な気持ちだけは作るなよと
相手に対して だからそれ以上な例は存在しないし
敵に対しても愛しましょうと言ったってもね
こちらはもう生でじりじりと鋸で切っても
その人々が幸福でいてほしいと心で穏やかで
親の心で見守るというのは
仏教でいう慈悲なんです
反対の意見を言う人は
そんなことしたってあんた殺されるでしょ？と
やっぱりぶん殴った方がいいんじゃないかというふうに言うかもしれません
でも仏教の場合は でもそれでも慈悲っていうのはその時やるもんだよと
ぶん殴るんじゃないんだと
相手を それであるお坊さんにお釈迦様が聞いたんですよ
このあんた これから伝道に行くでしょ？このパンナってお坊さんなんですけどね
でも あんたの地方の人々は乱暴でね
えらい口が荒っぽいんだよと
あなたは侮辱します しますよ
お坊さん お釈迦様は侮辱したぐらいでね
私はもう何も思わない
私はこの人々はなんて親切でしょうかと
ただ侮辱するだけだと
殴ったりはしません そう思いますよと言ったら
お釈迦様 それは甘いんだよと
その人は侮辱するだけじゃなくて
殴ったりすることもありますよと言ったら
お釈迦様 それでも私はね
ただ侮辱して殴ったぐらいでね
私に怪我させたりしないんだから
やっぱり親切な人々だと思いますよと言ったら
あれ甘い あなたはその人々はあまりも乱暴でね
侮辱してあんた殴って怪我させることもありますよ
重傷を負うこともありますよ
だからやめた方がいいんじゃないんですかと
伝道に行くのは それでこんな長老がお釈迦様
それでも私はその地方の人々はものすごい親切だと思いますよ
なぜかというと ちょっと侮辱しただけで
殴っただけでね まあちょっと怪我したさせただけでね
それで殺してないでしょ？だからやっぱりこの人々は親切だよと
殺そうとしないんだから
私のこと 言ったらお釈迦様はね
と言っても あの人々はね
あまりも乱暴でね 侮辱したり
殴ったり 怪我させたり
あなたを殺したりする可能性ありますよ
だから考え直したらいかがでしょうかと
伝道に行くことと言ったら
こんな長老が 私は殺してもね
私はそういう人々はとても親切だと思いますよ
なぜかというと この生きることは 1 日でもね
苦しいんだと 他の人々は自分は誰か殺してくれないかと探している人もいるんだよ
と 生き生きたくなくて自殺しようといっていろいろ工夫する人もいるんだと
それで私にしても もう悟っている方だからね
こんなこの苦しみを作ってくる
この体を背負ってね  1 日でも長生きするっていうことはかなりきついんだよと
これで無料でただでね
早く殺してくれるんだったら
この人々こそ親切やと
決して嫌な人だと思わないんだ
でお釈迦様ははい その通りですと
それが伝道する人の心構えですと
言って伝道しなさいと
だからもう野暮切りで
あんた死ぬだけ 死んだらバカでしょう
もう殴ったってもいいんじゃないかっていう風に言われる正当防衛
仏教にとってはあんまり
あんまり関係ないんですね
それさえもありがたく思う
だからこの強烈な慈悲なんだよ
教えているのは ものすごい強烈なんです
絶対理屈はきかない 慈悲の場合は
無言で守れと 文句言うなよと
いちいち理由探すなよ
どこかのテキストで見返りを求めない愛こそ素晴らしい愛だと
うるさい そんなこと 仏教はそんな状態じゃないんです
見返り思うとかね 見返りじゃなくて
自分を殺しちゃっても相手に対して慈しみますみたいな
それできればたった一行で生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますように
たった一行で生きる問題はすべて解決します
この世の中で 会社の問題
家族の問題 友人の問題
国際問題 何であろうとも解決する
たった一行で これは聖書にもできん
コーランにもできん ヒンドゥーのウパニシャッドにもできん
ブッダのとのたった一行だけ生かしてみると
で すべての問題が解決する
だから悲しいことは間違ってないと世の中の人々は実行しないしね
だからこれが間違ってないんだから
誰も実行しない なんかおかしいこと言ったっけ？世の中はもう実行しようとするのは全部間違ってることなんですね
間違ってない 正しいものだったらいつでも頭ます
いつでも頭ます というか
批判 反論 私にも結構 もう何かこういう講演なんか気持ちよく楽しく作れたら
その時に限って誰かからもうなんかもう文句くれんが返ってくる
だからその時に限って私はすっごく腹が立つんですよ
せっかくこのみんなのことを慈しんで思ってやろうとする時に
だけど 別に私もやることなくて
うろうろしている時はもう相手にしてあげますけど
なんで計算してそういう時に電話するかと
だって相手は知ってるんだから
私のスケジュールは私よりも知ってますよ
私はもう明日何やるか忘れてますけどね
複雑でね そんな覚えるのは
だから明日何かってわからない
まあ明日になって行くんです
で その中 すごく楽で楽しく生活できるし
で まあそういう風にいろいろ難しいところはありますけどね
やっぱりこの仏教はこう語るべき
こう語るべきと言っちゃうとね
これは失礼ですよ あるいは私の日本語はちょっとまあまあもうちょっととか
なんとかそうやってなんとか教えるべきところで教えてくれるんだったらね
いいんですが 仏教そのものがもうもう云々って言っちゃうと
まあこれで私が人間関係は切る
その自由は仏教にあります
必ずしも人間関係を持たなくちゃいけないということもないんだからね
嫌だったら切ると 嫌だったらではなくてね
うまくいかないんだったらね
で なんでそこですごいこういう風に神経質になるかというと
私はこの人の批判やら言葉っていうのはもう無視しているように感じてるでしょ
あ そうっていう感じでね
そうじゃないんです ものすごく聞き入れるんです
なぜかというと 人間には不完全なんですよ
私がいくら説法したっても
完璧になるはずがないんです
だから何かちょっとだけでも言ったら
これはやっぱりずっと心の中で計算して
なるほどなるほど なるほど
こういうこと こういうこととかね
そこら辺 こういう風にしなくちゃいけないとね
そこで私の話し方とブッダの教えは
ここら辺は言わないでくれという態度になってくると
まあではまあ貯金と あるいはあんたのあれ
あの発想がそうじゃないんだよという人
あ そうですか それはもう日本の方々が教えてくれないとね
まあよくないですよ まあだからこの
今日 まあ慈悲の話に戻りますけど
このごちゃごちゃ物事を複雑に
考えるんじゃなくて だからそのピヨの問題は
それをどうやって解決したんですかというと
やっぱり慈悲で 慈悲をその人には捨てようと思ったんだけど
やっぱりそれはあかんと
人間が自分がすごい精神的に悩んで
それを私のせいにしているだけやと
だから精神的に悩んでいることだけは確かですから
まあ私は大人げないんだと
ということでまあ落ち着いたんですけど
まあその間はまあもうシャワーをしたり
いろいろ遊んだり 時間は無駄に過ごしたんです
それで仏教の慈悲っていうのは
何の条件もなく ただ生命に対して親切にしなさい
それで損するか 損するとこじゃない
それが道であって それで終わりだ
道っていうことは 私たちは期待するものは何でもその道で得るはずなんです
だから天国はあるかないか
そんなややこしいことを考えなくてもいいんですよ
地上の人間は神に作られても
ゾウさんに作られてもいいんじゃないんです
そんなのは 人間が生きるべき道っていうものあるんだから
それが教えてるでしょ
あらゆる聖書の中で もろもろの
それでお釈迦様は一行にその生きる道を教えているんです
生きとし生けるものがと言われております
生きとし生けるものがと言ったところで
サッビーサッタン 見てください
誰も言わん言葉でしょう
どこでも条件付ける だから私は使っている
無差別な慈悲だと その方が私と面白い表現
表現なんです なんか無差別って言ったらなんか残酷なような気がするしね
だから私はそれと慈悲と合わせて仏教は無差別な慈悲だと
それを覚えておいて実践してみてください
そのもう その その瞬間からもううまくいきます
何かトラブル トラブルを起こし起こりそうになってくると
だいたいトラブルを起こりそうになるのは
もうこちらで感情が出てくる時なんですよ
で 感情出そうになってくると
まあ感情はしょうがないんですけど
で まあ一人で部屋で怒っていたってもね
まああまり良くないんですけどね
で 感情起こりそうになってくると
自分が失敗する可能性はあります
感情をむき出しにした瞬間に
人間関係は死んでいる
ですから その瞬間にこの言葉で処理する
これはまあ無差別な慈悲になりますかと
いくらなんでも だから無差別な慈悲だから
そうすると やっぱりダメだということで落ち着いて感情がなくなってうまくいきます
だからもう賢者はすごいシンプルですということはね
単に慈悲だけあればすべて解決するということになります
それでこのエモーショナル感情的な攻撃もなくなりますよ
だから 精神的な病気の人々は消えます
この精神的な病気というのは感情に攻撃されたということですよ
それで このシンプリシティの英語の反対の言葉はなんですか？コンプレックスでしょ
心理学ではコンプレックスというのは病気ですね
だからガチャガチャガチャガチャ考えること自体は
西洋的に見ても病気なんです
それから日常生活の場合は
みんなこの複雑になるのは
一つはこの自分の行為に対して期待しすぎ
これはバカしかやらないことなんですよ
だから研究したっても
何か開発したっても このあまり期待しない方がいいんですよ
何か例えば何か 何て言いますか
えっとえっとえっとえっと
作品を作ったってもね
これが売れるぞとかね
期待しない方がいいんです
私がやっていることには
期待の度合いはどれぐらい知ってますか？ゼロ
私はゼロにしているんです
そこでほんのちょっと売れたって
まあいいんじゃないかっていうぐらいで
しかし 一般の複雑な人々はもう 100 にするんですよ
期待は 100 にして もっとというふうに頑張るんですね
本当は結果はまあ 0.5 ぐらいとかね
実際は そんなもんだから
ゼロにした方がそういう分楽しいんですよ
そこであのアメリカの友達喋った時は
こので この仏教を広めるために
この何て言いますか この新聞広告やらね
あるいはいろんな方法でビラを配ったりと
いろいろ方法ありますからね
そしたらどうなるでしょうか
でもお金かかりますよ
それでそちらから言われた結果は
やっぱりまあそういうことをたくさんのお金がかかってやっても
成功率はやっぱり 0.012ぐらいだと
もし まあ 1 割  1 割前半ぐらいは結構あったら最高の宣伝になるんだけど
だから買え買え買えといくら言ったっても
それ飛んで買う人はいないしね
いろんな例えば日本では駅とかいろんなとこたくさん配ったり配ったり配ったりするでしょ
それもらうもらう人はその品物を買ったりしちゃうと
もう世界が成り立ちませんね
だからもうほとんど少ないんですよ
だからもう 100 分の 1 といえばびっくりするほどの結果なんです
100人に話しかけて一人が入ってきたら
これすごいびっくりだと
本当は1000人に話しかけると
嫌で嫌で一人ぐらい来ると
実際の成功率っていうのはそんなもんだから
いい加減現実主義になりなさいっていうことは仏教の立場なんです
自分の行動に対して期待はそんなゼロにした方が正しいんです
それだったらもうすごい楽に生きてられます
それで期待しないんだから
いい加減でやるわけじゃないんですよ
いい加減に仕事をするとつまらなくて
つまらなくて 気持ち悪くて
もう怒りになるんですよ
仕事は真面目にやる 自分の力全部出してやる
しかし 期待度はゼロと
そこら辺なんです すごく管理できればね
もう誰でもゼロ以上はもらえる
成功は来るんです しかし
100 で成功することは絶対あり得ない
それは宝くじが当たるような感じで
たまたま誰かに当たるとこはありますけど
それはあまり科学的な研究の材料になりません
たまたま本が売れたんだと
世界的に そんなのは期待しない方がいいんです
そんなのはたまたまで
その時でも単純というのがポイントなんですよ
例えば 今私は覚えているのは
あれやハリーポッターの本がなんで世界的にすごい売れてしまって
それだけでとんでもない金持ちになったんですからね
まあその方 作家は あれ単純だからなんですよ
だからシンプリシティという単純さにはすごいことがあるんです
だから 言葉の能力を見せるためにいろいろからくりをして美しく書こうではないかと思っちゃうと
もう売れない ただ単純な文章で
短い文章で 何々やるは何々であると
それぐらいの単純で書けばうまくいきます
これ書く時はね とにかくこの
えーと 我々にはなぜ単純にならないかというと
この物に自分のやっていることには期待しすぎ
期待しすぎ それでごちゃごちゃ考えちゃう
なぜ期待してはいけないかというと
それはすごい論理なんですよ
私がやっていることは成功するかしないかということは
私の管轄ではありません
例えば 私は本を作ったりする
その本はみんな買うか買わない
いわゆる売れるか売れないかということは
私の管轄ではないんです
だからそれ期待してどうするんですか
自分で管理できないところだから
だから物事の成果っていうのは
自分の仕事と働きと他人との関係なんです
そういう条件がたくさん揃ったところでヒットになる
だからヒットを作ることはできません
音楽でも何でも たまたまヒットになるだけ
上を向いて歩こうよとかね
なんであの歌なんかいろんな他の国々でも知ってるみたいですけどね
私はやってませんだけどね
もうこけますからね とにかくこの
あれ すごい単純で私さえわかるんですよ
歌を聞いてると 今は他の人々が歌ってる歌って
あれ？何？日本語何？って全然わからないんだから
それは私だけじゃ日本人もわからないんですよ
だからいつでもこの歌詞が下
テレビだったら字幕としていくでしょ
あれ読んでもわからないんですよ
日本の方々はわかるかはわかりませんだけど
あれ何？何言ってるんですかね？とかね
しかしね 本当に愛されている歌っていうのはわかるでしょ
上を向いて歩きましょう
涙をこぼれないようにで
すごいシンプルで美しい
だからやっぱりヒット商品作るものじゃないんです
シンプルで仕事をするものはヒットになる
だから期待しない方がいい ０
にする それは しかし 自分ではすごい単純
単純な思考でシンプルな思考で楽しく自分の仕事をやる
文章を書くんだったら
書いた本人がいいものできちゃったと喜ばないと相手も喜んでくれないんですよ
すごくそこら辺で考えてほしい
もう一つ こういうあの
何といいますか オールインクルーシブというかね
すべてまとめる答え もう一つはあります
あの生きとし生けるもの幸せでありますようにだけではなくて
それは最初にも触れましたけど
すべては無常であるということ
一切は無常であると で
たった真理 ただそれだけ
だからくよくよする必要はない
こうだからああなります
ああだからこうなりますとかね
こうしたらこうしたらこう考えたらこう考えたらこうなりますとかね
何の意味もなく 全部無常だから
もう で この無常っていうことで
この智慧っていうのは無常から現れるもんでしょ
このお釈迦様とお釈迦様に修行して悟った方々は
もうそこで単純化を目指しているんですね
目指してないんです 単純なんです
あるお釈迦様 これは本当かわかりませんだけど
あるお釈迦様の弟子であるある女性の方がね
まあもうたくさん子供を産んで
ものすごい立派な男ばっかしで
でお父さんも元気で お父さんと息子たちが並べていたら
誰がお父親かわからないぐらい
みんな体力がある人々で
それで軍隊に入りましたと
政府の王様の側に それで王様が気に入っちゃって
このグループはすごく可愛いし
格好もよろしいし だから一応司令官みたいなところに上がってるんですね
なんか嫉妬されたみたい
他の人々に どう見たっても父親と息子たち
たくさん息子たちが同じ軍隊で一緒にいると
この親子関係っていうのはきついもんだから
もうかなり硬いでしょう
誰にも入ることはできない
で これ嫉妬されちゃって
王様にいろいろ密告して
あのグループはもうあまりにも力があって
ちょっと危ないとか で
王様もこれの話に噂に乗って
まあ全部殺しちゃったんです
それでこの奥さんの方がもう敬虔な仏教の人で
このサーリプッタ尊者やらお坊さんたちに教えているんだと
お布施食事をしている間で手紙が来る
彼女は手紙を開けてみて
そのまま畳んでこちらにつけておいたと
何のこともなく見てつけておいて
また食事のお坊さんたちの食事のお世話をしていた
そこで召使いの女の人が次にお坊さんたちに配らなくちゃいけない
このヨーグルトみたいなものがあって
その入れ物はもう落としちゃったんです
これは普通の陶器で作るものだから
これ割れちゃったんです
割れたらたくさんのお坊さんたちには
その次の食べ物はもう配れなくなっちゃうんですね
それでサーリプッタ尊者がそれを見て
もう名前はマリカなんですけど
この彼女のマリカ 気にするもんじゃないよと言ったんです
マリカ そういうの気にするもんじゃないよと
本当は大変なもので たくさんのお坊さんたちがいるところでね
食べ物の一部なくなっちゃうとね
それまで一番高価なもので
で 彼女はそれに何も反応しないで
一応食事終わって終わったところでサーリプッタ尊者にこう言うんですね
お坊様はね 私にあれ こぼれたことをね
気にすんなよって教えたでしょ？でも私にこのこの公から
あの いわゆる王様のね
使者からね 手紙が来た
見たんですか？見ましたよ
その手紙の内容を知ってますか？と
手紙の内容を読み上げたんです
王様は反逆者として 自分の旦那とすべての息子たちは全部死刑にしたと
でも 私は全然びくとも思わなかったんだよと
だからこれがすごい  誰にも真似できることではないんですけどね
だからちょっとサーリプッタ尊者の方が辛かったかもしれません
だから私はあれぐらいのことに気にするかと
そこで素晴らしいと あんたはね
彼女は第一預流果に悟ってた人でね
あんた素晴らしいよと
どのように考えて あなたはどこまで落ち着いているか
と やっぱり一切は無常であって
自分の希望通りに行くものではありませんと
それが理解していきますよ
...何にもビクビクしないし
感情移入したりすることはなくて
穏やかでいる それで本当に修行を進んでいる人々は一切無常であるということで
とてもシンプルできているんです
だから この無常っていうのは素晴らしい言葉なんです
ではなくて 事実です 素晴らしいだけじゃないんです
すごい事実なんです だから無常って
なんで仏教とは暗くて
そんな暗い考え方と言われるんですけど
その人々ほど暗いバカな人々はいません
仏教とはなぜ明るいかというと
無常だからなんです 怯がないんですよ
地獄に行ったらどうしようかとかね
よく言われますよ あなた方は悪魔の教えではない
そうということですね
全然気にしない 相手に悪魔とは言わないんです
我々は 言ったらこちらは悪いことをしたことになるんだからね
まあ誰でも道徳を守って頑張りましょうと
結局は行為によって結果だからね
もう死後はキリスト教か仏教かということじゃありませんと
行為によりますよと っていうふうなことで見ていて
だからこの無常っていうのはすごく素晴らしいことで
無常だから ちょっと工夫すると我々に必要な方向へ変えることもできます
ですから このまあ 何か大きな問題が起きても
まあそんな無常だからね
気にするもんかっていう風に思って単純になる
今ショックですけどね
コーヒー一杯でも飲むときはそれは消えるでしょうとかね
本でも読めばというものは消えるでしょう
そういうふうなことで
すべて無常であることはすごい単純化にすることができます
それからもう一つ例なんですけど
あの それからなんで複雑にするかってもう一つあります
自信がないね 人間には
自信がないと 私にできるでしょうか？うまくいくでしょうか
どうでしょうかと考えちゃうんですよ
計画を立てたりいろいろするんだろ
自信がないんだからなんですよ
だから自信付ければいいんです
仏教で信仰と信というのは
この自信のことなんです
信じることじゃないんです
確信のことなんです サッダーと信というのは
ですから自信を持てばいいんですよ
そうすると頭が単純になるんです
自信がないと頭が複雑になるだけじゃなくて
もうもう神経質になって手足も震えることになるんですよ
合うわけがない だから自信つけましょう
できないと思ってやってしょ
それは自信できるわけない
これがおかしいんですよ
世の中でね できないことをやるわけじゃないんです
手を叩いて空を飛ぼうと思う人間はいません
だからあんたこの仕事をやりなさいという場合は
確実にそれできることですよ
例えば会社の女の人がコピーばっかりしているんだと
そこで五分時間があって
課長がね あの五分以内でこのコピーを一万部
コピー取ってください
一番も必要だから これできる？だからそんな仕事を頼む人は頭いい
それ気にするなくてもいいんですよ
だいたい一本分作ってホチキスで止めてください
言っちゃうと言う場合は
だいたい言う人も一日二日ぐらい時間くれるんですよ
明日に用意してくださいと
だったらできるでしょ
だからできない仕事を頼めるわけじゃない
なのに なんで自信ないんですかね
それはバカだからなんです
ということは 頭が複雑ということになります
だから自信つけるということは
とんにとっても簡単なことです
一つ呪文があります それには自信つけるために
これ教えてはいいかどうか分かりません
だけど すごい大事な呪文なんですよ
その呪文となれば 即自信つけます
この呪文って何というかといったら
やればできる ただそれだけなんです
だからやるかやらないかっていうぐらいのことで
やればできるでしょ やればできる
その人はしかし やる気にならないと言うかもしれません
それはもう具体的なやればできるんだけど
やる気にならない そこは別に
またどこかで他のことを複雑にぐちゃぐちゃ考えているかも
あるいは期待しているかもしれません
結果は だからこの世の中で自信っていうのは単純で
もうやればできる世界なんですよ
小芝さんがそういう本を出してます
えっ？誰？ 小芝さん ノーベル賞
あ そうですか なるほど
だからそれはまあ そういう人々も言うならばね
まあそんなもんだと思いますよ
まあそんなもんじゃなくて
そんなもんですよ 私もやればできるんだけど
やりませんよと それで終わりますから
別にもう後ろめたく感じる必要も何もないし
やればできるんだけど
やりません それでいつでも自信つけて生活してほしい
自信があれば簡単に簡単になる
それから この皆様の仕事の世界での分析能力をつけてもらわないと
いわゆるカテゴライズすること
分類すること 例えば仕事があって
これ大きい仕事だなと思ったら
やる気がなくなるんですよ
それでお釈迦様がやったように
全部徹底的に分析する
分析するとできるようになります
それからこのお釈迦様がこのそれの一つ
素晴らしい例を残してるんですよ
この三蔵経の中でこの長部経典という長い経典をまとめている経典があります
結構もう大事な経典をまとめたって
そこで一番目の経典は長部経典の
長いんですよ すっごく
で ラングザーラ教というんですけど
この世界で現れる これから現れようともする
人間に考えられる一切の宗教的な思考っていうのをまとめているんです
しかし お釈迦様は分類するんだから
ちゃんと分類しています
過去を考察して作る宗教
将来を考察して作る宗教
現在のことを照合させて作る宗教と
3つに分けてあって そこで分類しています
大体あの  32種類に入っています
に分類しています それ見てみると
世の中 これからも人間がどう踏ん張って新しい宗教思考を作っても
あの中の一つに入るんですよ
見事な分類 そこで人類
当時でインドであった宗教なんですけど
あれほど各宗教哲学を分類して
お釈迦様は言葉 お釈迦様の言葉も出さなくちゃあかんでしょ
お釈迦様の言葉は一行で終わります
だから仏教はいかに物事を単純にするかと
で 面白いことは これなかなか発見しないんですよ
このブラフマダラ経典を読む人々は
インドにこういう宗教ありました
こういう宗教ありましたと勉強するんであって
ではブッダはそちらにどうやって答えているんですかと
見つからない だって一行だから見つかるはずもないんですね
みんなも焦って読んでるし
また理解しないで読むっていうことはね
よくあるしね 読んでるんだけど理解はしないと
理解して読んでみると
ブッダの答えは何なのかというと
たった一行 そこで私の先生なんですけど
もうかなり何年も研究して
もうすごい立派な大教授で
なんかそのポイントテーマに引っかかって
結構長い間研究していたんですって
これ 私たちは仕事に就くときには面接とかなんとかあるんだから
そちらにいたんですね
で その先生がみんなに質問しながら
いきなり突然これ出しちゃったんです
このブラフマダラ経典にこうこうあるんですけど
で 哲学を分析していることは誰でもわかるでしょう
あんたはわかるでしょ
しかし それはブッダの答えがないんですかと
それに対して で 誰にも答えられなかったんですね
で 私はみんな知ってるんだから
面接に行ったっても なんかあっち見たりこっち見たり遊んだりとかね
もうなんかすごいもう軽い雰囲気でいたんですけど
まあで 私にも同じことを聞いたんで
私は聞いたら他の先生と別の話していたんですね
していた間で この人は先生もこれ聞いたんで
私はその先生の顔も見ないで
ドッテ先生と言ってその文章を言ったんです
先生はあのあっちあるでしょって
そんな感じで そこで下にありますよと
あのチェヒパッサヤトにプッサプッサパティサンヒディって言ってあるんでしょうと
あまりにも感触で それであの先生飛び上がったんです
そこ座っていたんだけど
これやと  それでもう もうそれからみんなもうバッてで
私を選んで選んでしまっちゃったんです
だからこの単純というのはすごいことで
先生にしたっても考えた末に発見したんだからね
その量はあるんだけど
この中身をね  それから私をいろいろなことを教えてくれて
結構育てましたけどね
その先生が私を で でお釈迦様答え言いますよ
だからこの結局はみんな目で見て
耳で聞いて それ感覚のことを語っているんでしょうと
だから目で見ても ただ目で見えるものは色と形だけでしょうし
耳で聞いたっても聞くのは音だけでしょうに
そんなものを頭でゴチャゴチャと考えて
まあゴチャゴチャってことはないんですけど
まあ言ってるだけです
しかし それは無常でしょうと
因縁によって生まれるものだからということで
何のことなく 一言葉であれほどのブッダの哲学をポイとする
それが単純な世界なんです
単純さの例についてはそれほどの経典はないんです
そこでパティパダはこれから出てくるかもしれませんですけど
お釈迦様はかなりインスタント主義だと私はかけたかったんですけど
やっぱりみんなに嫌がられたんです
その言葉には インスタント主義ですよ
とにかく ということは
あまり例えばコーヒー飲料で言ったら
このコーヒー豆を持ってきて
それからあれで あの 何て言いますか
煎て 煎て言うんですか？まあロースティングと
ロースティングして それから豆挽いて
それからポツンポツンポツンとね
ややくせに ややこしくて面倒くさくて
まあそれでもうまくできるかないかわからないしね
あんなポットでお湯を入れてインスタント飲んだら
早いしね どうせ体に悪いもんだからね
あんなものはもう だからインスタントの方がいいんですよ
あの ちゃんと淹れたコーヒーっていうのはそのまま淹れたもんだから
体に対する悪さもすごいひどいんですよ
それはまあ別に何なさってもいいんですけど
インスタントと言ったって悪いわけじゃないということなんです
それで やっぱり人間には暇がないんですね
いつ死ぬかわからないんですよ
だから悟りぐらいはインスタントでないと
コーヒーには3時間かかっても
もう死んだったら飲まないんだからね
コーヒーが入れる前に前に死にましたと
それはいいんだけど 死ぬ前に悟らなくちゃいけないんですよ
だからもう悟りぐらいはインスタントでやらないと
ということで 仏教は全体的にインスタント主義なんです
そこでブッダの教えは何なのかと
という疑問にね お釈迦様にね
悪いことするな してはいけません
いいことをしなさい それから心をしっかり育てろ
それで終わりということなんです
すごくコンパクトに言います
だから膨大な経典なくても
じゃあ悪いと思うものを全部やめればいいんです
自分で悪いと思いものも
人が悪いというものは悪い
じゃあやめたと 単純でしょ
これはいいことですよ
だったらやりますと そして心は綺麗に保つ
悩んだり苦しんだりしないで
それで全部仏教を語られているんです
それであれほど単純に語っている仏教はなんで我々にわからないんですかね
世界であれほどインスタント主義者がいませんよ
それで単純でシンプルでいうと
仏教ほど単純シンプルなことはないんです
最近読んだ本で 仏教はあまりにもシンプルすぎやと泣いてるんですね
あまりにもバカもんやと思いますけど
だから仏教でしょうに
と言いたいんでしょう
私はね それで このなぜ単純シンプルな仏教は我々にわからないかというと
我々の頭の中 ゴミだらけだからなんです
複雑で だからゴミのたまり場に誰が高価なね
何か持っていくんですかね
例えばゴミのたまり場で臭い
臭いところで イタリア製の家具とかね
持って行ってきちんと置いたって入るわけないでしょう
そういうことで 我々の頭っていうのはゴミのたまり場で
ウジ虫がいっぱいあって
ハエがいっぱいいて どこにもならん状態なんですね
だからブッダの単純な教えが入らないんですよ
だからそのゴミを捨てちゃえば簡単に
あ なんだ 仏教はそんな簡単じゃんではないかということになるんです
そこで質問みたいなものがありまして
こちらで聞いているのは
この うん 複雑な やっぱり仕事は複雑だったらうまくいい結果には出てこないということはわかった上の質問なんですけど
不幸を作るのは難しく考えたらいくらでも難しくなってしまいますが
そこはそれなりにやってしまいますという
誰かテレビでね 有名な人が言ったんだそうで
だからなんとなく作っちゃえばうまく売れるっていうことで
しかし 自分にとっては
まあ仕事はよいしょっていう感じでやらないと上手くいかないんだと
だからそれが本人がすごい自分にも単純にできないことは悩んでるんですね
これはコピーを書く人の話なんですけどね
これはちょっとその方の勘違いで
まあ私にしたっても やることはよし
やるぞというふうな気持ちをまとめないとね
やる気にはならないんですから
それは単純さとは関係ないんです
例えば仕事は単純にしたとします
したっても よし やるかという感じにならないと
もう途中で諦めてくなっちゃうんです
じゃあやめようと だからそれは別なこと
何て言いますか あれは
やる気ですか  やる気 なんかもう
決意ですね  決意というか
まあではやるぞというふうなね
気合 気合 あれ 気合入れることは別に問題はありません
でも 楽しくてたまらんだったら気合っていうものはいらないんですよ
しかし この楽しくたまらないということは
ものすごい智慧が優れている状態なんですね
智慧がない場合はそんなに楽しくはないんですけど
その時はちょっと気合入れないとね
特にこの仕事を単純にすると
ちょっと気合入れる必要があるんです
まあ大体まあそんなところで終了いたします